foreign
hey Andrew welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey
what's up
um we've been working through baby step
two for about four months and doing
December but so far I thought me and my
wife are debating about having a
birthday party for our two kids as her
sister who doesn't come down very often
is going to be over about two months
which lines up with that
um should I argue with her about it or
do they should I just shut up and put it
in the budget
I'm sorry
you're arguing about a birthday party
for your children whether you can afford
that
yes what are you
spending on a birthday party for
children
not ton but I'm just in what's a term is
that 50 bucks or 500 bucks a couple
hundred bucks probably like probably up
to four to five probably on the Range
and these children are held
okay all right
uh well so the one-year-old birthday
party is really for the adults
no no that's why I'm asking
um
and so I I you know
are people invited to this a big party
or inviting a lot of people or is this
more just for the family family okay
does your wife cook
she could I mean she could like make a
cake
like my mom did for my birthday I never
had a store-bought cake until I was in
college
I didn't know you could get a cake at
the store I didn't know that was an
option
and I and I haven't said that one time
to a therapist I've made it okay
so I mean you know good old Duncan Hines
right
um so I mean I think you could have a
whale of a party for a hundred bucks if
you kind of put your heads together yes
I think you ought to have a birthday
party for your children but do we have
to have
um six dancing ponies that cost two
thousand dollars no we'll just skip the
petting zoo and the Inflatables this
year
yeah go to the dollar store and get some
cheap decorum plates it'll cost you five
bucks hey and let me tell you what
happens with Sharon and me too is we
start arguing about Concepts and we've
actually ended up with actual similar
numbers in our heads like she's got this
big party in her mind for instance maybe
you got a small party in your mind and
if you actually sat down and wrote out
what you're going to spend both of you
would probably wouldn't be that far
apart
how could we do how could we do the part
you know a good question would be I
think a party is very important this is
you talking to your wife I think a party
is very important it's really important
for a one-year-old that we celebrate
that we don't you only get one of those
we don't want to miss out on that okay
and uh so let's have a big party how can
we do that given that we have this goal
of of trying to remain reasonable with
our budgeting and so what are you
thinking of spending
and how can we you know how can we do
how can we get a lot of bang for our
buck and I'll help
you know
um I'll get out the directions and bake
a cake if you could do that it wouldn't
kill you and um I could probably pull it
off and I'm really stuck in the kitchen
but I could probably pull off a cake
might take a couple tries but still be
cheaper than buying one Dave just
auditioned for the Great British Bake
Off this happened there there's a thing
called the British Bakery it's big on
Netflix the kids watch it okay but
Andrew the key here is you don't want to
set you back on your debt free Journey
you might be closer than you think you
are when you have a discussion
that's not about do a party or not do a
party it's more about what do we spend
on a party that is reasonable
and when Sharon and I start doing that
she's kind of talking in these flowery
terms about buying you know redecorating
the home and I'm like okay crap I just
heard two hundred thousand dollars and
she's thinking two thousand dollars I
just wanted another thing in there you
know and I'm like oh I should have shut
up and listened okay because I I she
said redecorate I heard 200 she was
saying you know 2003 you know what I'm
saying yes sometimes you miss each other
because all I hear is one thing in my
head goes warning warning warning yeah
you dig into the details you heard
partying you went my budget is busted
I'm trashed Dave Ramsey is going to come
to my house and hit me with a baseball
bat no none of that's true okay it's not
going to happen well you can go to
Costco and get two pizzas and a sheet
cake for like 30 bucks and call it a day
see now there you went buying cakes
again you can get a sheet cake at Costco
30 bucks yeah they put your face on it
whatever you want to do they'll do it
how is it that you know this George I've
been known to shop your Costco put your
face
you can do anything
a charge cake Dave I'm sure people have
sent you cases your face
has that not happened yet we didn't eat
those no that's that's not edible
there's something weird about cutting
into your own face
it's uncomfortable
I worry about what's in that cake but
how do you Dave how do you grapple with
folks that are in baby step two and
things come up we had one about a
quinceanera and she was gonna spend
eight thousand dollars because she
needed to go on the cruise for her niece
for the quinceanera and we said nope
you're not going on the cruise nope so
what is the what are the boundary
conversations you need to have what are
the financial pieces that you need to go
I mean what if
you had to do something you really
couldn't afford what would you say
okay in order to make the 16 year old
niece happy you need to buy her a 600
000 Bentley
you would go well that's stupid of
course I'm not doing that hey I don't
have six hundred thousand dollars B I
don't have a Bentley so she's sure not
getting one so see I hadn't been on a
cruise so I'm sure not going on one for
you
you know and I don't have eight thousand
dollars because I'm broke people in debt
but you gotta you gotta extrapolate this
stuff in your mind to go the absurdity
of the request
if you if you just pan back and go what
if it was at a zero to it you would go
well no well that's the way we're
looking at it when you bring up
something like spending eight thousand
dollars on a child's child's Cruise
while you're broke now we know why
you're broke this is the Ramsay show